[Music]
if you look into those activity in the
Silicon Valley in around the world you
can see that a lot of big company
actually acquired a lot of good design
studio you can see that it happened
demand a wide aside matter and what is
the design in financial service mean
when this actually embedded in DVS four
years ago actually it changing the way
we would be focusing on customer tie-up
you actually helped us to form a better
problem statement when you have a design
team in your organization they actually
can help you to inspire what could be in
the future
decide actually drive the shareholder
value so our benchmark when you want to
build a design team in DB as we say okay
we want to be a world-class which means
that we need to set our standard to
those companies like Airbnb Facebook
Google Amazon and Apple
our first inside him in in the bangor
city starting from the sky so he
actually starting the campaign go hire
more than banker and those are my cell
and the three designer we sat in the
small room our team actually a loss of
discipline because seven had of ux this
should be a good keep nicely standing in
any company when you have a buy a big
size of project to handle different
makes a different actually one of the
thing that we has tried to build the
team we visit our team today we have 150
people and then they coming from 13
country we do a lot of things care so as
we won as a team
[Music]
for the designer in the digital will
actually be try to measure that we build
something that people really used so we
try to look into high frequency and high
pin so those are the thing that helping
the most UX is not just about the decide
so or not just make it pretty or the
screen but it can be about content even
deeper it actually those object give you
some where you give you some feeling
that okay actually I have that cat is
actually companionship be our login
screens how can we create as emotional
value up to it so we just make the login
very simple have a photo to the bill
then we built as a public CMS which mean
you can change photo anytime and we make
secure environment for the logins make
sure that no one can hack that one and
when we do that we actually try to
rotate the image to Lee later like the
foreign morning lunchtime evening should
be changing as well because we quite fun
him and you log in that night and you
have a photo in the morning
so we seen that and then people see why
you have to do that is people don't care
actually people care and they actually
keep a lot of cool stuff on this one
peak balance is a function that we bill
with because we kind of know that when
sorry coming in people start to log into
our system to just for three seconds you
gotta want to make sure the money in so
we build something that you don't need
to log in you slide on that and you can
see the balance immediately Paila p2p so
we build this app but we trying to make
it more fun like we add some animation
to help make sure that you know you get
the feedback that I should be sending
the money to the other side
in our all his self we actually working
with a lot of team we work with finance
legal research marketing risk management
T&O and also his showers so like even
our headshot planner so here so we will
closely with a lot of cross-party on
that's why is really make us successful
I'm lucky that my boss actually did
sandy was my boss and he understand the
design an even Sushant also talk about
design designer actually we are part of
the company so this is feel meeting that
we have every year we also at the table
as well to mention that we actually part
of the strategy moving forward not just
like taking order the last one is
important because that's what make
parent the one the kid to be a designer
I have been in the support twenty plus V
and then I saw that sorry oh sorry that
sleek going up and up it's not very easy
to replace it ai or anything so I think
designer have a role to play in the next
like 10 20 years a lot of companies are
to have those the c-suite of designer we
have in Pepsi actually we have one but
she stepped out but she actually do a
lot of this I culture at PepsiCo Airbnb
actually start from designer Nike also
have one Samsung one so happened a lot
of companies start to have shifty
surfaces not even recently BBC actually
looking for cheap these are busy as well
so actually have been expanding I got
from or twice to be eating and become a
meet your kids have room to grow okay
don't worry that they will start
somewhere
you
[Music]